[Music]
so yeah so this one is amazing besides
the flipping all these moves are
actually pretty real compared to what we
practice as a kid because when we do
this when he does this one holding his
sword up it's a technique that we use to
show that we have the sword power
because in the Chinese martial we have
what we call the Heavenly sword and it's
it's the exact same technique that we
use for the Heavenly sword first cut the
heaven cut the Earth and cut the people
when I was learning I saw that childhood
of course we get the same exact
technique most of them you know it's
like such a striking pairing blocking
cutting and of course we would add like
a lot of acrobats to the to our
performance aspect of it I think the
Skyward Sword is most realistic